okay so it's time to introduce our first  guest and i don't know who it is um i  hope they like margaritas and cases and  if they don't leave  please welcome the star of one of my  favorite shows on television come on out  whoever you are  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my gosh  [Music]  so basically  i'm on a date drinking with nathan  filling that's what's happening i'm just  kidding i'm just kidding i am i have no  idea i literally have nothing no idea we  wanted to surprise you okay okay but i  didn't want this to be the only surprise  oh it's enough can i bring some more oh  yeah or please say okay i want to you  guys to all welcome please welcome uh  makia cox  alyssa diaz melissa o'neil and erica  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you